comme suspect de se trouve sur room 404
un petit jeu d'horreur qui a l'air
terrifié ligne je le dis avec l'accen
dessus tellement elle est terrifiée
alors j'ai juste la tête avec la bof moi
et ce à moins de 200 tonnes à l'hectare
est super c'est d'ailleurs un but choix
c'est vraiment une démo ou quoi y a plus
de sens en réseau fait qu'elle ait pas
fini son discours à l'eau ya quelqu un
assez bon ça marche [ __ ] la vache
c'est déjà tout un périple pour juste
arrivé à lancer le jeu mais ça c'est le
bon jeu d'horreur ça les boucles
d'oreilles sens pas facilement autres
l'aston souviennent se lançait pas comme
ça ok c'est parti alors apparemment son
fils est mort devant lui et il se
retourne chez lui où je sais pas quelle
bêtise la brève à y avoir des monstres
et des portes qui s'ouvrent toutes
seules
auj alors ça c'est de la qualité oser le
dire le contraire au bout de cent
vingt-six minutes on peut enfin jouer au
[ __ ] de jeu ben opus est pas dégueu en
vrai c'est pas dégueu des gueux en soit
on est bien d'accord
o'holla [ __ ] et m'a surpris dit dont il
m'a surpris le sais quoi c'est logique
j'ai peur à cause de la d'accord c'était
pas le branchement en fait à je suis
tout tendues du coup ça m'a surpris
d'être surpris par un art boyer basses
extrêmes en salle ont fait le tour par
la voilà le tour est fait oh [ __ ] en
tout cas on va dans un endroit propre
les gens sortent les poubelles ça c'est
plutôt rare allez c'est parti
le 20 10 à quand ils te casse l'ambiance
au je vais pas faire le malin et je vais
tout de suite cherché à lampe torche ou
interrupteur ses moyens
qu'est ce qui sonne à l'eau au revoir
écoutez c'était un très bon moment une
discussion intense vraiment alors ici on
a energy box pourra trouver des fusibles
où une poignée énergybox levet ben ouais
bah voilà la poignée qui était vraiment
extrêmement dur à trouver on peut le
dire et voilà cela est fait à salou la
grille du coup qu'est ce qu'on a ici des
squelettes si un mois par les côtes mais
c'est très intéressant c'est passionnant
mais on peut pas prendre la clé là est
un mec je suis sur quoi a besoin de clé
retenez bien moi j'ai le flair mois à
une autre clé là aussi en fait juste et
que les des chambres s'en fout je pense
ok bon on a fait le tour du lieu et
c'est ça c'est des ongles de pieds voilà
le mec s'est coupé donc de pilot est
donc très très long [ __ ] c'était le
wolverine des pieds qu'est ce qu'on a
ici sait faire mais bon j'ai compris
vous voulez en venir vous voulez qu'on
aille
direction la grille attendait c'est
fermé alors on va aller par là où nous
ont dit d'aller donc la crise ouverte
juste derrière nous ben y'a rien ça
souffre pas tant mieux tant mieux parce
que ça c'est une pièce sont là je pense
à un marché toujours pas à toi ya aucune
banque qui s'ouvre oh la la
non mais plus s'il vous plaît monsieur
s'il vous plaît à quel moment tu rentres
dans cet endroit on a trouvé la 404 ces
noms du jeu attention la 403 est ce
qu'elle est ouverte
bien sûr que non la 404 seul nom de jeu
tête de mule peut y aller la 404 qui est
bien tout au fond du couloir à droite
tous les types d'animaux sont morts dans
cet endroit y compris les humains s
ouvre pas c'est pas possible ça chambre
[ __ ] c'est un sketch c'est un sketch à
cela c'est ouvert ça c'était s'est pas
ouvert avant on se souviendrait sinon
moi je vous le dit ben voilà il clé et
c'est la clé de la voix ou de pouvoir
ken klee qui positionne étagères et
ouais le flair et à personne à l'avoir
house on est bon on n'est pas mal du
tout pour la clé de la game room la
salle de jeux excusez moi je cherche la
game boy game of games mais c'est moi du
tout vrai tout seul est ce que c'est
parce aguëro voilà c'est la grande
double porte du tout début
et là je suis sûr que là ya le petit
fils et à petite fille je suis pas
pressée jours une petite fille avec des
cheveux longs et noirs dans ses jeux etc
a plein de mascara qui a coulé sous les
yeux c'est vrai me demandez pas pourquoi
j'en sais rien [ __ ] mais c'est
toujours comme ça et comme c'est un
homme c'est un mec avec un ventre énorme
et souvent un couteau à la main et la
moitié du visage en moins alors une
petite à choisir je préfère encore la
petite fille c'est quoi ça je sens de
faire quoi là bas il faut que je trouve
un code tout simplement oui ce [ __ ] de
code je vais trouver un sk aux quatre
regardez c'est marc keller 4,04 et un
visage d'une femme qui hurle pas ce qui
se fait piquer le torse donc le code c 4
104 postes évident et voilà haut et on a
la clé de la chan 414 c'est quoi ce
délire c'est quoi c'est quoi ça va
s'étendre alors là effectivement là on a
un mix entre le entre l'homme aux grands
comptes et la petite fille
là c'est un homme et du mascara et un
ventre semi mon gros elle est allée dans
la chambre 404 bien sûr un mois parce
qu'il touchait en 404 c'est le moment de
se faire couper la gorge dans
d'affreuses souffrances attention on est
vraiment bien rodé on est même débridée
maintenant on aimait plus que rodez x
est en bacs de qualité les gens ont
apprécié et ont tous mis en live direct
j'ai vu un j'ai vu les laïcs augmenté
non ok jean pierre sueur garde ces
moments c'est le moment s'te plaît fais
pas ta fdp la femme en robe la cua
baddou bon je reviens en arrière ma voix
en or ça a changé
regardez je peux plus revenir là vers la
vie à la salle de jeux et tout matériel
une photo d'une
qui se passe là après on fait tourner et
serviettes de patrick sébastien a alors
fait tourner les tableaux voilà c'était
l'instant beaux fruits pour un petit peu
décompressé allez on s'en va à la pointe
400 une qui est totalement fermé bien
sûr est ce qu'on va mourir comme cette
femme sur la photo
bah oui on voit que mec je vois rien si
moi je voyais vous j'imagine même pas
trop mal non mais laissez les c'est une
petite veilleuse au moins juste une
petite vidéo s comme pour les enfants
comme ça on peut voir voilà comme ça
paye allez allez hop ans et je joue à
rien ok c'est la femme de ménage de
l'hôtel on y croit elle veut me serrer
la main qui ce cas là ça n'a aucun sens
si c'était quoi ce cri fait-maison la
noë dernier qui suivent l'élection de
téléphone qui écrit dans sa cuisine et
on se réveille sur un parquet attend
mais cccc aucun sens je suis outrée et
mais je devais même fragilisé devant
tant de d'aucun sans citer tous à nous
et je sais que tout est fermé ça sert à
rien d'essayer tout va être [ __ ] de
fermer qui se sait une sculpture
quel est le poids c'est tout c'est assez
rarement une démo d'une démo j'ai plus
peur sur l'écran d'accueil que dans le
jeu en vrai nom l'agencé gère 37 2
j'espère que vous a quand même plus même
si c'est très court n'était pas elle est
évident aussi c'est le cas pour écouter
la vidéo demain sera plus longue c'est
une que je le joue dû aller un petit
verre de sirop et on oublie tout allez
allez allez fais pas ton team et de mon
garçon va écouter pour une démo en vrai
c'est pas dégueu mais [ __ ] je pensais
que ce serait quand même un peu plus
long a donc j'en attends plus de room
404 et j'attends la room 405 la blague
la moins qualitative du monde
alors cette vidéo un rythme jugé vas-y
tient tout le monde portez vous bien à
demain en pis